real housewives of salt lake city star
jen shaw pleads guilty in her federal
fraud case and now she's facing up to 14
years in prison not seeing racy or omar
for eight years do you know how [ __ ]
scared i am jen appeared in front of a
judge in manhattan federal court for the
surprise hearing on monday where she
changed her previous not guilty plea
since the reality star has now pled
guilty to one count of conspiracy to
commit wire fraud in connection with
telemarketing the us attorney dropped
the second count conspiracy to commit
money laundering the judge warned that
she faces a maximum penalty of 30 years
in prison and five years of supervised
release however jen's plea agreement
called for only 11 to 14 years behind
bars and restitution of up to 9.5
million dollars
this is
devastating
for me personally and more so for my
family jen was arrested in march 2021
for her alleged involvement in a
long-running telemarketing scam which
targeted people across the united states
many over the age of 55. you'll recall
her arrest aired on season two of real
housewives of salt lake city
what is going on
why are the police here we're looking
for 10 shaw
what the heck is going on she just left
wait jim if they were asking about jen
you guys what if she's on the run ahead
of the episode airing jen's cast mates
shared their reactions with e.t it was
so out of left field
that we thought that jen left the bus
and hired strippers yes because and i
and i said that i was like clear the
bags we have strippers jen hired
strippers because it was homeland
security fbi nypd and a swat team yeah
and lisa and i were like their outfits
don't even match i know literally we
were like okay who is this what is going
on it was crazy there's a reason why
kumbaya is at the beginning of the
series
so it was so unbelievable that you
thought these were strippers this was a
joke this was another yeah i thought it
was a prank i was like where's the pizza
yeah there were two looking there were
too many of them and they were too fully
equipped in gear that we've never seen
in utah for them to be actual you know
law enforcement now jen's guilty plea
comes as a surprise because just last
month when she sat down with youtuber
adam newell she doubled down on her
innocence i'm fighting for my freedom
i'm innocent i'm not guilty of any of
these
of these
charges that i you know that i've been
accused of i'm innocent to me this is
like
this is the only option for me is to is
to fight is to show
everybody out there that we're so quick
to jump on the bandwagon and make
assumptions that you know what i'm
innocent and you fight for your freedom
and you fight
you fight to
vindicate your name and not in your
family's name jen's trial is set to
begin on july 18th sentencing is
scheduled for november 28th